Olha o que você me faz fazer para chamar
a sua atenção você sabia que a melancia
além de refrescante oferece incríveis
benefícios pra sua saúde Ela é Rica em
antioxidantes como licopen na vitamina C
combate os adic Livres redu a inflamação
ajuda prevenir doenças crônicas e
envelhecimento precoce mas não para por
aí a melancia também cuida do seu
coração a citrulina presente nela
melhora a circulação sanguínea e pode
até ajudar a reduzir a pressão arterial
com mais de 90% de água essa fruta age
como diurético natural eliminando
toxinas e prevenindo a retenção de
líquidos e tem mais a melancia fortalece
o sistema de defesa o sistema imune e
ajuda na digestão e pode até ter efeitos
anticancerígenos nos protegendo contra
certos tipos de câncer tudo isso em uma
única fruta melancia é muito mais do que
refresco é saúde em cada pedaço